[Music]
I think people often Overlook the
overlap between Japanese Shonen manga
and Western superhero comics granted the
art styles are usually pretty different
usually both have their unique tropes
but we can agree that it's fun to read
stories about eccentric characters with
tragic backstories running around in
colorful outfits and fighting each other
with superpowers likewise both of these
translate pretty well and do animation
and today we're going to look at all of
Japan's attempts to bring their style
and sensibilities to the world of Marvel
Superheroes East Meets West in the
wonderfully weird world of Marvel anime
and here to help me since I'm not a huge
anime guy one of the most prominent and
well-known anime YouTubers out there
come on down Mike literally my ocular
Globes have never made contact with the
Japanese person ah he's just being
humble this guy is the ultimate weeb
lives and breathes the Land of the
Rising Sun he uses Chopsticks to pick
his nose I'm talking the biggest Naruto
fan I have met in my life Ryan geeko had
some huge boobs I mean some serious
Honkers I mean a real set of badonkers
packing some
roast some massive the hookah Bank of
those big old time to hunger Baraka give
her a buck I don't know who that is but
this is Anime we're talking about so
it's probably right Wolverine
Wolverine's first solo comic featured
him going on an adventure to Japan to
chase after his long lost love Maraka
yashida After he finds out she's been
forced into an arranged marriage by her
abusive Crime Boss Father Lord shingen
along the way Wolverine meets a badass
assassin Femme Fatale named Yukio who
wants to help him take down shingen for
her own personal reasons and they have a
complicated relationship the story ends
with Wolverine stabbing shingen in the
throat and Marico agreeing to marry him
after Yukio kills the criminal scumbag
she was stuck with naturally all of this
would fall apart into complete chaos
shortly after in the mainline X-Men
books because Marvel characters are
generally not allowed to get married but
it was a really cool first Arc for the
old kanucklehead that established a few
nice Side characters for him to use in
future stories so for translator
Wolverine in anime this four issue Arc
felt like a perfect choice since it
already took place in Japan featured a
lot of Japanese speaking characters and
is one of Wolverine's most famous story
lines in the comics the anime retells
the story pretty Faithfully for the
first few episodes with some minor
changes for one instead of Marico being
married already by the time Wolverine
gets to the Land of the Rising Sun in
the series she's only engaged with the
marriage happening soon
this creates a nice tick and clock
element to make things a little more
exciting and give Logan some motivation
to keep the action going so he can stop
it from happening instead of just like
getting really depressed and doing
drunken bar fights like in the book also
for some reason a lot of the characters
names are changed slightly like marico's
[ __ ] criminal husband in the book is
named noburo Hideki but in the show it's
Hideki kurohagi or Wolverine's secret
agent friend from Japan asano Kimura was
changed to Tesh and asano other than
that they have pretty much the same
personality and are drawn to look the
same so I'll just call these characters
by the common name between both versions
for simplicity's sake and because I'm
already getting confused by all these
names I can barely pronounce because I'm
not that flavor of Asian Filipino
represent there's quite a few parts of
this adaptation ripped right from the
comic like Wolverine and shingen's duel
with the wooden swords where shingen
wins by cheating and being a dick or
Wolverine finding that asano has been
killed in his office this version of the
story also tries to add more greater
Marvel Universe references so Hideki is
in charge of the island of madrapore and
also gets funding for his criminal
Enterprises from Aim plus Cyclops shows
up Midway through the series to help
transport Wolverine and Yukio from Japan
to madrapore since an Island full of
criminals and mercenaries would be a
cool place for the third Act
I know you can handle yourself this
guy's got some heavy backing you know
what
just stick to flying the plane naturally
Wolverine is a dick to Cyclops the
entire time for no reason I think it's
just the sexual tension now I'd say the
biggest point of Divergence in this
Show's telling of the events is with the
ending and how they handle the character
of Yukio in the book her loyalties are
very complicated she's an assassin
working for shingen to gain Wolverine's
trust but also she hates shingen and she
instantly falls in love with Wolverine
the second she sees him and is super
horny for him so she wants to help him
for real but is working for his enemy
and pretending to want to help him even
though she does
it's a mess eventually shingen gets wind
of her feelings for Logan and orders her
to kill asano to protect herself this
drives a permanent wedge between her and
Logan but is also the final straw that
forces her to give up working for
shingen forever and turn on him
all this weird Love Triangle stuff is a
little forced in my opinion and her
killing asano becomes sort of a lasting
stain on that character that makes it so
you can never truly be on her side again
same with Wolverine never being able to
fully trust her again even when she does
help him out the anime simplifies all of
this by just saying she's with Logan 100
from the start She Wants Revenge on
shingen for killing her mother instead
and she's not the one who kills asano
it's all more basic and trophy but it's
easier to wrap your head around and you
don't have to deal with the character
trying and failing to walk back such a
horrific betrayal plus she no longer
begs Wolverine for sex which was kind of
strange also instead of throwing little
knives at people she carries around a
circular blade that seems like it would
be really easy to cut yourself on when
you're holding it these changes to her
have a ripple effect that alters the
trajectory of the story
now asano's killer is an original
character made for the anime Kikyo who
has a really not that interesting
rivalry with Wolverine that the show
devotes a lot of time to even though
this character sucks hold on
we never found out which of us is the
best
you are
entire sword can suck into his hand and
go up into his arms somehow why does
this keep happening hey so
let me get this straight
bomb in the booth for multiple shows and
you then haven't killed two bars in one
stone
oh stupid idiots
why thank you
he shut down because I'm eating a wonton
he just had him voice this forgettable
chump five against one let's say we even
up the odds Sano what's up bud say the
word and I'll put him down for you
these guys are a bunch of pansies anyhow
Wolverine is instead voiced by Peter
Petrelli from Heroes
remember that show that overpowered son
of a [ __ ] oh I just need to be within
like a square mile of someone with
superpowers that I could permanently
copy their powers they had to like Nerf
him in season three when his dad showed
up who had like the same Powers kinda
his brother like Nathan Petrelli could
just fly
oh remember they also did that Arc where
like Seiler killed Nathan and then they
like put Nathan's brain in Seiler and
had his uh shape-shifting powers make
him like think he was Nathan the whole
time but it was actually seiler's body
just pretending to be him you remember
that uh no cause I'm not a millennial so
I don't know what you're talking about
I'm not totally loving this voice in
design for Wolverine like yeah he looks
close enough during Random clips of
fight scenes but when things slow down
for a moment and you really like look at
him this guy doesn't scream Wolverine to
me he's tall and thin he's young and
handsome looking and his youthful voice
doesn't have the same Graveler grit this
is very much a Japanese idea of a tough
guy protagonist with like a Dante Leon
kind of energy Ray's a badass but he's
also kind of pretty and uh feminine too
in a way and he's just
he's got these really kissable lips
you know he's got these long arms you
just kind of want to wrap around you oh
Jesus this Wolverine is unlocking some
things most the time in animated format
Wolverine's claws are used more
defensively to shy away from extreme
Gore in a show aimed at kids so you'd
think in a tvma series like this they
take full advantage of the claws and the
brutality of them for fight scenes but
it's kind of rare for him to use them
lethally in this show
that's reserved for the nameless goons
but important characters seem to be stab
proof until they've been fighting for a
good long while
and even then they often shy away from
showing the penetration look at this
Cinemax late night [ __ ] and as of
yet the best anime Wolverine fight
scenes remain in Hulk versus look he's
stabbing and there's blood look he cut
off that guy's [ __ ] arm and you can
see the bone look he's getting horribly
injured and you could see it the anime
doesn't even take full advantage of
showcasing his healing powers either
which seems like a wasted opportunity he
gets hurt a little he sees a minor
bloody wounds or some Burns I want them
to whittle him down with automatic
gunfire to a screaming silver skeleton
covered in tendons or something we have
the rating for it be creative guys I
will say that other than not liking
Wolverine's look himself this shows art
styles pretty over rendered these
characters are so detailed in ways they
almost don't really need to be if that
makes sense the hair and skin and
clothes on these characters are shaded
so intensely everyone's outfits are more
wrinkly than a John romita Jr drawing
somehow yukio's suit is shaded like it's
really baggy and loose but drawn as if
it's skin tight so it just kind of looks
confusing to my stupid brain and what
the [ __ ] is with Omega Reds whips the
shading on these is ridiculous like yeah
that does look like reflective metal but
God those poor animators I guess I'm
more used to animated stuff where the
shading is more minimalist with two-tone
colors detail is nice but too much of it
can clutter the intended visuals anywho
most of the villains in the show are
boring OneNote OCS but they did throw a
mega red in there to mix things up with
an actual Comic character as the show
goes on it starts to drift further and
further from the events of the book and
I admittedly find myself carrying less
and less all this stuff in madrapore is
dull and slow and I don't care about the
subplot where we meet yukio's uh Revenge
hungry grandpa I guess
or like I think they fight a giant
statue guy there's almost a few episodes
in here you could skip without really
losing anything important but it all
culminates in a wolverine barging into
hideki's heavily fortified skyscraper
and
doing a really tonally dissonant
reference to The Graduate like it's shot
for shot here and I can't tell if it's
supposed to be funny or not hey the way
they fall off this balcony into a pool
kind of kind of looks familiar remember
that
[Music]
out of the botched wedding to Wolverine
Arc and the long war between her clan
and the hand and her brother Silver
Samurai before she's poisoned by the
leader of the hand the show just has
Hideki shoot Morocco in an accident she
dies right there in the finale Wolverine
beats shingen in a battle and Yukio just
walks out of frame because she was only
there for revenge and like the final
shot of the show is Wolverine carrying
marico's dead bodies he screams into the
sky
just saw
sending sucks plus there's this bizarre
post-credits scene where Wolverine once
again faces off of kikio and it's
supposed to be like hype but I don't
care about any of this it's strange the
anime starts off really strong and then
veers off the plot from the comic and
then sputters out into this really
underwhelming finale where everything
Wolverine fought for becomes pointless
and it's just a bummer
such is the way of Wolverine he's held
so many dead love interests in his arms
I've lost count please you know how many
girlfriends have died in my arms now
word from our sponsor special thanks to
today's sponsor established titles
established titles is a Project based on
historic Scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
Lords and Ladies in English they allow
you to buy as little as one square foot
of dedicated land so you can be an
official Lord or lady what would you do
with one square foot of land plant a
tree on it establish titles as a fun and
novel way to preserve the natural
Woodlands of Scotland while helping
Global reforestation efforts your square
foot of land will be on a private estate
in edelston Scotland and you'll receive
an official certificate with a Crest
your certificate features a unique plot
number in which you can see the exact
location of your land and tree
established titles will plant a tree
with every order and will work with
global Charities one tree planted and
trees for the future to support
reforestation worldwide and because
you're a lord or lady you can change
your name to that on documents like
credit cards plane tickets or dating
profiles if you think it'll help your
chances it makes a great last minute
gift I actually got one for my dad and
my sister they even have couple packs
that come with adjoining plots of land
it's 200 people purchasing a title pack
using my link will effectively be next
to my Mendoza family plot within a few
minutes of walking distance depending on
how many of you want to become our Lord
or lady we can build a little Godzilla
Mendoza Kingdom established titles is
actually running in early Black Friday
sale plus if you use the code gmzilla
you get an additional 10 off go to
established titles.com forward slash
gmzilla to get your gifts now and help
support the channel now back to the
video
next Iron Man and then X-Men later blade
I got it from here why'd you give me
this one what I don't give a [ __ ] about
Iron Man uh look at me I'm Tony Stark
guy I have so much Charisma a Circa
2008. I am no longer willing to be
slaughtered out in this iron prison but
no no hold up wait a minute my Prodigy
that I've been printed on has to learn a
similar lesson but in a juvenile and
disciplinary context so in turn I feel
the need to force my ideology onto him
but I'd enforce it due to codependency
and I'm [ __ ] on full moms pull up the
[ __ ] he's just James Bond in a Gundam
suit again Circa 2008 I guess
[Music]
most if not all media with the character
after Robert Downey Jr's portrayal
borrow from his interpretation heavily
not really giving him any room to be
anything but an arrogant ass even though
the films eventually evolved from that
with him ultimately being whittled down
to a schizophrenic loudmouth this series
does so kind of loosely with character
traits involving Tony and some
Aesthetics but mostly leads it to the
side presumably due to its setting in
Japan having him stationed there to
establish cooperation with the Japanese
government with his new arc station
technology and new deal Armor going into
mass production acting as a replacement
for Iron Man following Tony's retirement
deal
[ __ ]
but once the new armor is hijacked and
he confronts a member of the so-called
zodiac he armors up the hunt for the
ones behind the catastrophic events that
follow take anything I say about the
show with a grain of salt because my
lack of knowledge involved in the
character which is limited to the prior
mentioned movie appearances his video
game appearances outside of said movie
titans most animated appearances and for
good measure
my car is impression of him what Gerald
[Music]
shut them the [ __ ] up I haven't dived
into his Source material deep Cuts Like
I have with other characters that deeply
interest me so excuse me if this is
actually a bad show but a great Iron Man
Show maybe he's actually very upfront in
a creepy way and not in a confident
charismatic way in his approach to women
in the movies got that backwards I don't
know I think I know what your next
question is it's what everyone wants to
know sooner or later oh really and what
question is that does Tony Stark close
his eyes when he kisses
[Music]
no unacceptable this character takes a
weird flip because he still is RDJ light
for most of it and it's time for you
think he's getting pretty serious but
then he makes a really juvenile remark
equip in the middle of a dire situation
this will be sweet but the series does
take him pretty seriously around the
middle Mark I thought I'd hate him
starting off because of his blade and
disregard for most people and things
like he kicked the dog on some pita [ __ ]
but then he has a change of heart as it
goes along weirdly enough every other
piece of media that's not the movies
outside of our main Adventures haven't
put him in Pepper together so he
actually tries settling down with Dr
Tanaka who's an assistant to him with
The Arc station you see him actively go
out of his way to help people just as
Tony which like outside of Iron Man
three were General audiences isn't seen
much it's too bad that I absolutely hate
his voice acting he always sounds like
he's trying to be way too cool which
logically I don't understand thinking it
fit his character but instead of doing
so he just sounds really dramatic like
the emotions associated with the
situation he's in or foreign to him and
he always has to sound Sigma oxygen
supply all good to go but there's still
one issue I need to solve and that is oh
no biggie really just haven't quite
perfected the particle radiation shields
for the armor yet the rest of the
characters and voice acting is fine if
not over the top but that's to be
expected with this medium there are
Norris is here and he's just Jay Jonah
Jameson from spectacular again
internet's down again
huh what was that everybody has a role
to fill don't ask me why I'm using
quotations I'll kill you with my bare
hands there's more focus on this plot
than character which is fine but with
the dot pacing it doesn't really give
you any one to be attached to but the
Japanese reporters who meet my Tony
until they don't an army and Ichiro
there's a few episodes where they're
entitled to the plot but they're largely
forgotten now by the series no they're a
constant that I wasn't necessarily
getting annoyed with but they're for
sure getting into that Godzilla versus
Kong School of 90 to be here at all with
the scholarship Dr sanaka herself is
seemingly a face value love interest but
there's times where she's pretty
outspoken and takes a front seat to the
action hold on we have proof that a
virus is not the cause of this
though there are some weird decisions
decisions or character as the overall
series goes on that I'm not 100 rocking
with they're not super fleshed out or
whatever if anything they're kind of
uncomplicated but I had
notes on them so I I guess I felt the
need again maybe that's how Tony's
Supporting Cast is and this is just
super accurate I don't know what I do
know is that weirdly Avengers villains
get funneled into Tony's Rose gallery or
vice versa so that's why the Zodiac are
here but instead of weirdly themed
animal costumes they're all just robots
this series doesn't take much from his
villains at all though the cliche of his
villains being bigger and better
versions of him is a recurring topic I
see is valid that is an element I've
liked with the villains I've seen
they're more playing a part in the
bigger industry of the technology he
innovates on or being based and such and
with an arms race being a source of
conflict in this show it feels like it
could have used more of them but instead
it pushes that to the side for a
thriller plot that largely feels
disconnected and derivative the story
Narrows from being episodic to becoming
serialized Xavier's video on spectacular
proves it can be done well planning each
C4 to be expanded on and paid off by the
end but it doesn't have that same level
of development say like episodes closer
to the middle will put all their
attention on a certain storyline with
there being big events taking place to
play out later and then the next will
just kind of be passive about it with
one seen mentioning those events the
characters would just go on about
whatever new conflict comes up and not
press on anything involving it until
like two episodes later or even down to
the final few episodes with it starting
off in an episodic format the stories
are pretty simple which simple is fine
but it still moves to and from its story
beats in a rush at times this leaves
things feeling like they constantly come
from left field with threats they pick
up as the series goes on being very
vaguely hinted at initially in a way
that doesn't really leave you on the
edge of the Steep guessing but instead
leave you scratching your head
well guess how to be specific ultimately
notice series isn't very good at setting
a plot to us and desperately needs to
know from Power Rangers on how to set up
its mystery characters in relation to
its protagonist I'd say watch it for
yourselves and see if it's your thing
but I'm gonna be a fence sitting [ __ ]
on this one and say I'm in the middle
and you called Tony that one word a lot
it's really ugly seeing that written in
all caps
officer
respectfully
what the hell are you talking about the
X-Men anime series takes place right
after this universe's version of the
dark Phoenix Saga where Jean Gray is
dead in Big Air quotes and the team has
disbanded to process their grief but
Professor X is visited by a strange
psychic vision of a mutant boy in
trouble and gathers the team together
again to investigate a host of mutant
disappearances in Japan an area that is
mysteriously outside of Xavier's ability
to scan with cerebro along the way they
recruit Emma Frost to be the team's new
on-site telepath and armor from for some
uh for some Japanese mutant rep look
she's got those
those Miss Marvel Powers oh it appears
that I watched these in the right order
because now Wolverine is perfect this is
a huge step up from the other Wolverine
I mean look at his character design
that's a wolverine alright he's short
and beefy and he's got the right voice
thanks doctor obvious I love you Steve
Plessy where's the costume for a little
bit in this show delicious the show's
X-Men roster is pretty awesome and I
love the voice cast for this dub Cam
Clark is Professor X is something I'd
have never thought of but he Nails it
the X-Men have received a call for help
and we answer every call whether from
mutant or human
Leonardo's Professor X and Fred
tattershore as Beast is pretty cool
because you know he usually just gets
cast as the Hulk and doesn't get a ton
of speaking lines with his normal voice
he's normally just going
foreign
stuff you know and I really dig Scott
Porter of Cyclops I think he may
actually be my favorite voice for that
character Hank opened your eyes they
want to get mutants killing mutants and
so far we're playing right into their
hands and Ally Hills as Emma Frost is
cool oh [ __ ] she's [ __ ] lighting God
damn
this who this [ __ ] leave me be
she's balanced very well as characters
not any single one of them is given the
Limelight over the others and they all
share a pretty equal screen time
normally a lot of X-Men adaptations
around this time would play a little bit
of favoritism for Logan since he was so
popular back then but he's utilized well
here just the angry [ __ ] Diva of the
team and always punching Cyclops and
fits of Rage
because he secretly is in love plus
these character designs are way more
pleasant to look at I wish they kept
their more traditional costumes for like
more of the running time of this series
but these new designs aren't bad except
for peace face it looks like the
kangaroo guys and tank girl you look at
iced tea and tell me if there's an
ominous would be
he's just a guy
all right
yeah okay they're still pretty comic
Booky and cool I like cyclops's silly
shoulder pads I wouldn't mind some of
these being unlockable costumes in a
game or something actually overall I
just enjoy this Show's aesthetic more
than Wolverine because it's highly
detailed in all the right ways instead
of just looking visually loud
character designs don't fight against
the fluidity of the animation what have
we here
hey I recognize that sound effect
that was close this Show's story is
mostly original content I'd say that
part of is a lot more engaging for me
than the Wolverine stuff it's hard to
talk about it without going into
spoilers so I'll just say for sure that
I do recommend this show so here's where
spoiler talk ends so the x-fellows find
out that a bunch of mutants are being
kidnapped by robots in Japan because a
human scientist named yui suzaki is
there testing a cure for the x-gene on
them and is basically this universe is
equivalent of Moira McTaggart because
she used to have a relationship with
Charles her attempts at creating a cure
however have been causing mutants to
turn into crazy horrific Cronenberg
monsters instead of alleviating their
superpowered swelling yui also sells her
soul for this cause by working with
psychos like the you men who are nutty
transhumanist cultists that want to
steal mutant Powers themselves and uh
Jason Wingard from the inner circle of
the hellfire club normally he's not the
leader of that group but here he is for
some reason I thought it was Kevin Bacon
she's trying to cure the mutant
condition because she secretly had a son
with Professor X who's an Omega Level
mutant on the verge of causing
catastrophe with his out-of-control
powers it was a nice setup and payoff
here because the show starts with the
team failing to save Jean Gray when
she's lost control and here they try to
do it all over again with Charles's son
Takeo Sasaki who is based partially on
Legion in from the comics I guess oh
dude that's the show that made me want
to [ __ ] Aubry Plaza
that's
yeah we're that's going in the team's
major struggles throughout the show are
teaching armor to control her powers is
the newest and youngest member of the
team and cyclops learning to trust Emma
Frost after she was framed by the Inner
Circle for having a hand in Jean Gray's
death during this final episode Takeo
has finally set loose on the World by
Mastermind to wipe out humanity and
Charles puts out a psychic call to the
world's Heroes to help the X-Men stop
him so we get a bunch of cool cameos
like Nightcrawler Iron Man Rogue
Colossus Archangel oh he's a Deadpool
this came out before the game so he's
just there like looking cool and and
like menacing instead of like
fornicating with a burrito and singing
show tunes or whatever
I like the black coloring on the outside
of his mask seems so it matches his
torso that's kind of neat I've never
seen that before the show's got a lot of
heart to its story and some very fun
moments and it's just nice seeing a
relatively small X-Men team in animated
form again since the 90s show you know
since that was the only one trying to
keep its cast tight and focused this
series knows what it's going for and
conveys the qualities of X-Men we know
and love in a fresh way and I had a good
time watching it check it out
subscribe
I was born that night tainted by the
same Eagle that killed my mother
that's why whenever I hunt I keep in
mind the warning my mentor gave me
he always used to tell me to guard my
soul when looking at the darkness
because the darkness
is always looking back there's few
alternate universes I want to live on
though where Speed Racer found its
director and Ike Williams and the one
where every redesign of Blade had to
follow his initial appearances as
opposed to sticking with his movie look
we were pretty close with Greg
Smallwood's pitch of midnight Sons but
the world doesn't want us to have nice
things now does it they stuck us with
Ryan Reynolds as Hannibal King and he
quickly forgot about the hellstrom show
the hellstrom show
see what I mean Praise My sunblade his
name is Blade the show starts out with
the daywalker up to his usual
Supernatural investigative Endeavors
until he has a run-in with Deacon Frost
the man responsible for his mudblood
Heritage leaving him in an up-and-coming
vampire Hunter to go on a globetrotting
adventure to stop him from eradicating
all human life to get to the higher
accounts
that's like if you want you want to get
elected governor by destroying all the
world's grocery stores and restaurants
there's probably Mega Corp CEOs that can
get away with that in their respective
universes I came into the series
expecting Helsing ultimate light
material or Vampire Hunter D lots of
sick blade fights and super gory
elements with sick ass Gothic imagery to
set the tone and I wasn't entirely off
just not only to the point of scratch
the heroin infested holding my veins for
that type of stuff I was just waiting to
see a full red sky like Batman the
intermitted series or
well the bad man with every episode
featuring a blood moon but alas I was
surprised how little blood shows up in a
series about vampires even if this was
after the Disney merger it only gets
bloody closer to the end of the season
other than that all the violence is just
fiery deaths like in the movies which I
can't live without but it doesn't hurt
to get a little violent you're going to
spill every single thing you know or I'm
going to have Wall to heal peel your
dick like a banana for the most part I
actually like the action that takes
place it's pretty well paced and each
character doesn't stick to the same
fighting style that's a problem I had
with Iron Man there was too much of just
flying and Blasting and not a lot of
variation between them though this
series does seemingly cut Corners at
times but that's probably due to budget
constraints they're scenes that resort
to still images and flashes between them
to imply action some reused assets
though very few there's also this
recurring action of the and see what I
did there dump the deadly sword
technique and I thought it was a cool
idea based off the background they
showed us in the show but I would have
preferred if they used it more scarcely
throughout because it doesn't really
have any impact as the show goes on it's
like come on it's a super cool move you
gotta let me be hype whenever it shows
up I wanna be I did really get hyped
when they started the series off with
some smooth Blues but that really showed
up in favor of mostly Rock and
orchestral which isn't bad but I was
really feeling that sex that in the
two-tone color scene in the series I can
understand you watching it now and
thinking of it being a little hard to
look at with a lot of the environments
being few gray-centric colors or very
muddy but I think it helps the series
Aesthetics like with episode 2 seeming
like this weirdly out of place know your
story off the bat with the POV switch
that doesn't really focus on at all to
the start of the second act it's
especially favored when certain
environments stand out even little
things like as we follow the story with
the vampire hunting life the atmosphere
being very dreary and muted yet there's
a lot of warmer colors surrounding his
flashbacks of his younger years with his
foster mother but that dreariness slowly
seeping in from time to time as it goes
on what what's the smell
the show is surprisingly very character
focused with it giving us a lot of
blades upbringing it doesn't necessarily
give you every detail of his motivations
and mindset but it gives you a rough
idea of why he is the way he is and why
this path is the one he took with you
seeing a lot of his mentors and ever
series returned For Better or For Worse
I really liked how him and the
up-and-coming hunter Makoto are
approached when it comes to their
Dynamic she gets caught up with blade
after he kills her father during him
being infected with the sucking [ __ ]
disease and having to put him down but
she eventually realizes it's bigger than
her and decides to side with him she
doesn't really feel like an obligatory
sidekick Edition with her being kind of
the comic relief in a way that's
self-aware but not being overbearing and
taking nothing seriously she can just
find the humor in the situation she
finds herself in when it comes to this
whole journey well sounds like someone
means business yeah but it's none of our
business you do take me to the nicest
places other characters assume her and
blade are involved but luckily the
series has the restraint needed to keep
it professional unlike some other shows
plus there's an event Helsing descended
that shows up and he's pretty cool
acting as sort of an uncle role with all
this praise I can't give it the same
price when it comes to villains Deacon
Frost though I like his attitude at
times is pretty underwhelming and
honestly kind of has a confusing
motivation and Mission plan maybe I
wasn't paying attention enough I don't
know you know who caught my eye though
is this little feisty thing named Lucius
he's just so so silly just so goofy
you could say that he
puts me in a
silly goofy mood and I'm a pretty big
fan of the variation of creature design
shown throughout for some reason I
thought from the first episode it would
just take the vampire and werewolf
Warfare but a whole bunch of different
types of things show up and uh
you wanna hear from me but uh
the modern Argo is kind of bad though
whoa whoa whoa whoa what the what she
reminds me of Betty when she was a harpy
um well I guess the first time got what
I was getting into when I brought you on
I'd say watch it it's cool it's got some
cool moments some cool characters some
cool action and every episode ends on
some sick ass imagery true I felt very
little in killing him
but killing you will be a pleasure
[Music]
bring it
four so anyway everyone used to meme on
this show what I actually meant to say
was hi I'm Xavier I'm a black man now uh
we have a quota to film I have to make
money so in order to fill that quota
we're gonna go over the movies that mad
house made as well uh part of the
interruption uh thank you for complying
and on to the regularly scheduled
program this movie is like a weird
pseudo sequel the first live action one
but so are most Marvel things anyway now
Tony is working on a project to um
build a satellite surveillance system to
watch everyone on Earth and stop crimes
before they happen with predictive
algorithms I named this satellite Howard
after my dad who always watched out for
me major camp
reporting for Duty [ __ ] hypocrite but
then it's interrupted by this little
[ __ ] stain in an atom machine suit I am
the future what a blonde-haired
blue-eyed people always say that I can
probably give you a few reasons [ __ ]
about Iron Man is known here again but I
guess I have a question to Iron Man fans
out there and by extent the small amount
of Raiders fans that also happen to be
technibore fans it's technivore that big
of a deal when it comes to Iron Man I
was taken aback with his appearance here
because I'm used to him being this
cybernetic alien looking [ __ ] hole in
his
it's it's don't misgender the Nano
machine [ __ ] Hole Sun other animated
appearances then in this he's like a
symbiotic host to Nano machines and this
one and then he stays cooked up in this
room that kind of I look at it it kind
of reminds me of the oh God
so personally I'm just confused as what
this guy's thing is like I'm surprised
he shows up so much when he's only in
like two issues originally funnily
enough in the longer feature they decide
to hand in and make the suits as opposed
to them being CG the entire time I
prefer most of the art styles outside of
the main 4 Series initially made and
that goes for here too A lot of the time
in here they have Iron Man backlit in
contrast with the glowing Parts on the
suit and I think it enhances his design
he does have an oddly narrow abdomen
though which The Unsung Logistics of how
big the suits are in comparison to their
uses is kind of touched on with these
designs but maybe I'm still stuck to
Tony's weird goo that comes out of his
suit in the Ultimate Universe so the
entire satellite project goes ass up and
Roadie is buried under a collapsing
building and shit's crazy so Tony goes
on a quest to find this rat bastard
while Shield aggressively tries to
arrest him for
seemingly No Good Reason along the way
he teams up with the Punisher voiced by
Norman Reedus who gets top billing in
the credits despite being a rather minor
character a bunch of bleeding heart
Shield weaklings tell Nick a Screen
Actors get more crowded than voice
actors and it's irritating every goddamn
time oh God but Black Widow and Hawkeye
spend more time trying to rein in Iron
Man than hunt down the villain behind
the attack while Tony is trying
desperately to get to the bottom of the
mystery villain in his crazy Nano
machines
son along the way Iron Man realizes that
the villain is actually the unheard of
retcon child of Obadiah stain whom he
killed in the movie and that's Canon
here a little Ezekiel stain Wants
Revenge for his father and bonds with a
horrible Nano machine monster designed
by aim to destroy the world and then
there's a creepy Jeff Bridges in the
ceiling I don't have much to say about
this movie other than the dub cast it's
pretty good and I like how Iron Man
wears armor and pretty much the entire
damn movie The Plot and villain in this
feel a lot like a tech-based Resident
Evil story considering the villain's
creepy Eugenics themed motive and
grotesque body Transformations into a
huge monster at the end for some reason
Hawkeye won't stop smiling and it makes
him a hundred percent more punchable
black widow did not need to [ __ ] up the
Punisher this bad Jesus
oh hey Black Widow you want to start an
anime film with me Avengers
confrontational Avengers controversial
Avengers [ __ ] spider that eats his
husband's head in the Punisher this is a
direct sequel to technivore but the
voice cast is different kinda instead
this movie's annoying Screen Actor that
gets top billing is Jennifer Carpenter
as Black Widow whom you may know from
Dexter and quarantine
wait wait wait
foreign
she's not very good here please God just
hire voice actors to voice act No One's
Gonna drop everything they're doing and
buy this DVD just because they saw her
name on The Box what you don't like
as Mario once again Shield are annoying
and just ah [ __ ] stop getting into
everyone's [ __ ] they're just annoying
stop punisher's just doing his Punisher
thing they arrest Frank Castle for
killing guys they were gonna arrest and
then recruit him for a mission to stop
an evil spy organization from doing mind
control stuff and selling weapons or
something so Frank and Natasha put aside
their differences and team up to save
the day and then black widow's
ex-boyfriend is here dressed like the
Red Guardian but he's actually
it Egghead from the comics
what all the characters you could pull
you got him
why not just like make a new character
it's so wildly different anyway
yeah
let's make him
accessible to the millennials
yeah
the plot in this one's pretty thin it's
just kind of an excuse to run from
location to location killing bad guys
I like the art style better than
technivore here it's the same character
designs just drawn in a slightly more
appealing way at the end the bad guys
are in Magic poor and are readying their
attack when the Avengers show up to kick
some ass and Iron Man is explicitly
stated to be the same one from the other
movie so that's neat I guess this movie
isn't really that interesting but at
least they wrote Punisher in character
for both of these because he hates the
government he's more concerned about
reducing civilian casualties so acap
Punisher is cool I don't got much to say
about these movies except the last one
was swinging dick everywhere who the
[ __ ] was on the storyboard team they're
like dick what the [ __ ] you want to go
to majipur for so bad some dick
sorry but I'm not exactly sure what
you're getting at would you mind running
that bias again nothing's too convoluted
for you to wrap your brain around and
they just get to the point of their
stories pretty quickly I think they're
pretty funny time if you don't pay
attention which is totally not what me
and Xavier did because we're
professionals and we have integrity to
keep up and need to constantly be
observant with our jobs
[Music]
hey since this is a longer video I just
want to give a shout out to my pals
James and Maddie over Watchtower
database who recently published one of
their biggest and most ambitious
projects ever if you're a fan of the DC
Animated Universe or DC Comics in
general their channel is a super
in-depth Archive of Canon video essays
and lore analysis with a lot of humor
and some storytelling of their own
thrown in for their video discussing
Batman and Harley Quinn's place in DCA
you Cannon Jacob and I used our skills
combined to help put a funny cartoon
alien man in the video for them and some
of the live action sketches and he
sounds like Kurt Woodsmith dumbass so
this is interesting go check it out
everyone involved worked really hard on
it it's a great video
this feels like a show pitched as a
parody of the concept of an Avengers
anime in like 2005 like all the trophy
Toyota crap you'd expect a group of kids
with colorful hair run around with
collectible gadgets that allow them to
summon badasses to fight on their behalf
and each kid in the group has their own
special sidekick that they're bonded
with
the characters even shout the names of
the super moves they're doing in combat
oh
you know like Bakugan Yu-Gi-Oh Pokemon
Digimon Duel Masters and probably a
hundred others
these watches may as well have a Bandai
logo printed on them in the show
I guess someone figured kids would find
this show more relatable with young main
characters without powers to be a window
into the world of Marvel superheroes
a superhero like you and a regular kid
like me are the same precisely but what
if I told you of all the Marvel anime
I've seen
this one is by far my favorite
not only that but I genuinely think this
show kicks ass I'm not making a joke you
gotta hear me out like the premise makes
it sound terrible but you you gotta
watch it for yourself the series Focus
is primarily on Two Brothers Akira and
Hikaru whose dad abandoned them to work
at Stark Enterprises building a portable
device that can trap super villains in
small discs you know Iron Man he's
always building ethically questionable
detainment for criminals you designed
this holographic projection system so
you could communicate with the super
villains you imprisoned in the discs
exactly you don't get tired or hungry
and thanks to its healing property is
uncompletely recovered you only get
three Square meals a day or a bed to
sleep in you're just digitized onto a
[ __ ] flash drive where you're never
hungry or tired or even able to die just
permanently conscious in one Everlasting
uninterrupted moment only able to
communicate with the world through a
tiny incorporeal hologram indeed
you are
[Applause]
conceptually this is an inhuman [ __ ]
nightmare and everyone involved in this
is an [ __ ] but this service is a
handy plot device so these kids are able
to serve as the Arbiters and caretakers
of The Avengers
with their parents permission of course
this came out shortly after the first
Avengers movie so as you'd imagine Loki
is a central character and this series
starts with him crashing the unveiling
of these discs at the super villain
prison called The Raft in the attack he
forces all the Avengers into these
incomprehensible sci-fi prisons as well
as collects up all the villains that are
in the raft too in the scuffle all of
them are scattered all over the world so
we can also have that scavenger hunt
collect them all before the bad guys can
type of cartoon [ __ ] too what do we
do with these collect them and trade
them with our friends they might as well
be the talismans like that Jackie Chan
show or one of Stitch's 625 cousins
actually Dragon Ball was probably the
most obvious comparison but I didn't
really watch that as a kid conveniently
the accident also places a genetic code
into the two brothers and a few other
kids who are bystanders during the
attack so only they can control when the
Avengers are released from these discs
all the Avengers are also trapped in
these things almost indefinitely and can
only materialize into human form for a
few minutes before they're digitized
again
why is it necessary for the little red
backwards hat wearing kid to spin around
three times before letting Iron Man Out
of the Box because they need something
cool during these transformation scenes
and Iron Man can't dig evolve or
whatever the [ __ ]
the even weirder part of all this is
that the villains don't have the same
time limit problem and could
theoretically stay out of these stupid
discs indefinitely but for whatever
reason choose to be put in them anyway
so they can be summoned by other
villains so like you walk up on Johnny
bank robber about to kick his ass and
then he's like Modoc I choose you and
then Modoc starts shooting lasers at you
and it's
weird world we live in
speaking of everlasting uninterrupted
moments weirdly enough this show is
pretty easy to binge watch because every
episode pretty much leads directly into
the next Karu maybe you could use a
break too all of us have been through a
lot this last couple of days sometimes
five or six episodes at a time can take
place on the same day
I think it's so you feel less weird
about the horror of the Avengers being
trapped in Pokeballs but this show takes
place over a really short amount of time
despite having over 50 episodes
they even sometimes mention the events
of the previous episode as like that
thing that happened yesterday you seem
to have a good time with them yesterday
when you were playing video games
so I guess that this show takes place
over the course of a month or two at
most around the 10th episode Loki
disguised as a senator pull some strings
to get the superhero registration act
signed into law meaning superheroes are
either regulated or outlawed in the U.S
and this is an excuse for The Avengers
to hang out in Japan for the entire rest
of the show and so the animators can
draw more familiar background locations
I'm not sure how to feel about Iron Man
Kong the Japanese kid Samurai boy all
the time didn't even know you were a
superhero what do you call it Samurai
boy backwards cap kid Akira
you got time
you know what I mean Samurai boy would
you stop calling me that why does he
calling that what about Chris the blonde
kid from New York he doesn't call him
Samurai boy I think there's a racist
undertone to it but that's because I
read every action Iron Man takes is
uncharitably as possible so I gave my
company access to the security footage
across the entire Island complex is that
really okay to do all the studies prove
extensive surveillance is effective in
crime prevention and what is privacy
anyway Tony Stark is virtually motivated
you think given my track record of
vehemently hating Transformers Sidekicks
that I despise all these non-superhero
kids but they're actually really fleshed
out and likable characters
Akira rejects his schoolwork and scoffs
at science because he misses his father
but also resents him for leaving pairing
him with Iron Man is interesting because
Tony isn't exactly the fatherly type but
he and Akira start to bond over their
fun-loving attitudes and eventually
Akira decides he wants to go into
scientific Fields because you know he
wants to be more like his hero Hikaru
fully Embraces science from the start to
impress their dad once they meet up
again but he also had to become
overprotective and responsible for his
younger brother while they didn't have
parents to watch over them which Thor
finds relatable because he's always
chasing after his little brother and
feeling responsible for his actions
Jessica is the rich girl and speaks a
lot about giving to the less fortunate
but has an arc where she realizes that
these things are performative when in
practice she accidentally treats the
other kids as lesser for not being as
well off as she is and has to Humble
herself and treat them as equals [ __ ]
trust one baby Chris tries to appear
more mysterious and emotionally closed
off but identifies most with Captain
America for a strong sense of Duty and
responsibility to protect the younger
kids in the group he also has a hidden
passion for cooking that he's insecure
about the other kids knowing about an
adword is a little nerdy coward doofus
that ironically gets paired with the
Hulk
ah
he's the weakest character he actually
does suck I don't like him that much but
the rest are cool
capturing superheroes are an odd
storytelling choice but they go really
in depth with the concept and build the
world around them a lot of Heroes have
different reactions to them like
Wolverine finding them conceptually
appalling as they remind him of
Sentinels capturing mutants these discs
of yours could end up being just as bad
it's Sentinels all over again it could
never happen again we've learned from
our mistakes tell that to cyclops one
episode Falcon is Bravely injured in
battle and agrees to be contained in the
disc for its healing properties to save
his life while one episode later
Deadpool is faced with a similar
situation after Zemo attacks him with a
sword that negates his healing factor
and he decides that he'd rather die than
be trapped in that damn thing and takes
his chances with his stomach being
slashed open every hero who appears in
this is written in character and they're
all naturally very distinct from each
other which is why it's exciting that
this show has a ton of guest Heroes
popping in and out of the story who
aren't really affected by the disc stuff
like Spider-Man frequently checks in on
the trapped Avengers and we see he's
still got a life going on outside of the
events of this show
Amigo chimichanga take out
[Music]
and yes Deadpool is here after the game
came out so he's buying Mexican food and
shouting bang every time he shoots his
gun but
ironically I still like this Show's take
on him a whole lot because he's not
really aggressive or cruel he's weird
and eccentric but in a sort of Meek and
humble way so it comes across as more
endearing and other characters actually
find him occasionally funny huh what's
this
the disc was a fake he tricked us
[Laughter]
[Music]
I can't believe I trusted him Deadpool
you goofball yeah plus he does get a few
badass moments like his sword fight with
Zemo that gets taken pretty seriously
blade shows up and you can tell the
animators love the Wesley Snipes movies
because he does the same moves
[Music]
and he actually kills vampires here
plus the more obscure characters get
special attention like silver samurai or
the X-Men character surge since they're
you know some of the more prominent
Japanese Marvel characters kind of weird
that Silver Samurai is more prevalent
here than in the other show where
Wolverine is trying to date his
half-sister and kill his dad why was he
over there the character designs in this
show are an acquired taste at first I
didn't like them but they grow on you
and you know I like how rather than
using the movies as a basis some of them
are more noticeably referenced from the
other cartoons from this time like
Mandarin and Whiplash looking like
they're from Armored Adventures or
gravitons designed from Earth's
Mightiest Heroes and Doc Ock is a stupid
robot ball like an Ultimate Spider-Man
however the Guardians of the Galaxy are
pretty shamelessly just the movie
versions like one to one the original
character designs in here are Hit or
Miss like you know this doctor strange
is cool this Wolverine is nice but then
this Iron Fist is a little weird or like
Captain America looks like
the series shared a lead character
designer with Dragon Ball Z and
sometimes that really pops out like just
look at Red Skull he looks like a red
namekian or something these designs may
be pretty detailed but they can really
move when the time comes for a fight
scene and this Show's choreography is
awesome some of these battles are really
fluidly animated and showcase the
characters Powers perfect like look at
that look do you see that that was that
was awesome you see that one
[ __ ] you see that one order of sea snake
extra sunny
[ __ ] that was awesome
the fact that it's all hand animated
none of it is cheated with the
occasional 3D model too is nothing short
of impressive Iron Man suplexes Loki
from orbit in the last episode so you
know definitely definitely watch this
show or the series The Kids upgrade
their connections to the Avengers and
the discs allowing them to be free for
longer and longer and Iron Man even
comes up with cool finisher moves that
require the kid's help to use the kids
prove useful in a lot of creative ways
that justify their addition to the story
as well as add a bunch of stuff that
would you know easily turn into an
action figure I will mention that yes
we've been watching the dubs for all of
these and I know that there's a lot of
elitism and annoying conversations that
come from that and the anime fandoms
I'll just say that I kind of prefer just
watching the dub for these shows in
particular because these are
English-speaking characters from an
English-speaking country and you know it
makes a lot more sense to have it be in
English I could buy that you know maybe
Akira and Hikaru from disc Wars are just
like bilingual and just speak English
rather than every character from New
York also just speaks Japanese all the
time you know yeah
particular has a really amazing voice
cast for the dub are some of my favorite
casting choices for these particular
characters
Matt Mercer's Iron Man really grew on me
in this series and I love Roger Craig
Smith as Captain America and Steve Bloom
is Wolverine once again legitimizes any
project but this English dub is no
longer available to you officially
anywhere in HD it was only broadcast in
Southeast Asia for a short time and then
never again and the only surviving
recording of the dub is blurry has a
Disney XD Watermark and a bunch of full
commercial breaks I searched high and
low for this series but that HD English
dub was never released on DVD isn't
streaming anywhere and no longer airs on
any TV station in the world so
it's impossible to watch officially now
you may be asking but Xavier you've been
showing HD footage of the show with the
English dub throughout the whole review
so far so where'd you get that from
well I had to remaster the entire show
just for this video
took the footage from the Japanese
version turned off the subtitles sped it
up four percent to sync it to the
English version which is faster for some
reason and then did that for all 51
episodes I did the most episodes of
anyone but naturally this was a massive
undertaking so I brought some help from
a few of my YouTube Pals to get all done
in just under a week editors assembled
thanks to all these fantastic fellas for
taking the time to help me save the
English dub of this goofy animes from
obscurity sometimes I had to fix the
timing of the English version that
talked for a few seconds less or there
were shots with guns firing that were
censored out
and I put them back in
a lot of care and love went into this
remaster so it's you know it's kind of
my fan edit and uh unfortunately for
legal reasons though I can't release my
HD dub of the show you know it'd be
really bad to
Marvel is a corporation and
I guess Japan as a nation if that copy
just
leaked onto a bunch of
pirate sites anonymously
Mike if you developed a twitch what's
going on there what the hell are you
talking about you son of a [ __ ]
somebody costume
sorry yeah I really like this show and
it's fun character Dynamics it's cool
fight scenes and it's massive cast of
characters I like how heartfelt and
wholesome themes are and the finale is
fun and uh it's a shame the show is
pretty much impossible to watch now but
if you find a way
then give it a watch
future Avengers isn't about a new roster
of Heroes in the 22nd century or
something it's about the trainees that
will be Avengers someday it's not
explicitly connected to disc Wars but
it's meant to be a spiritual successor
the show starts with a team coming
across a group of kids that have been
given superpowers by Hydra and trained
to be assassins and villains for hire
but Tony Stark being a billionaire Tech
CEO jumps at the idea of exploding child
labor and brings them into the fullest
Sidekicks barring the inclusion of these
Hydra kids it's a much more standard
Avengers show with more usual stories
and maybe that's more your thing but it
interested me a little less part of what
made disc Wars unique was the irony that
the Earth's Mightiest Heroes were so
severely impeded by their predicament
the limitations of the discs stop them
from being as overpowered as they are
when they're unified and working at full
capacity and it was dramatic when these
normal kids were putting these extremely
dangerous and risky situations because
they were the only ones who could do it
these kids are all super and have
constantly evolving powers for direct
combat so they're really not that
different from The Avengers themselves
it's just four more superheroes added to
the roster and it's a little less
special if that makes sense
and frankly I don't like them as
characters nearly as much they're not as
strongly developed their voices are kind
of annoying and I don't even think their
powers are that cool if the kids are
just going to be young superheroes then
why even bother with OCS at all may as
well just have the future Avengers be uh
Kate Bishop Miss Marvel Nova and Iron
Art
maybe miles
like you know actual characters from the
comics one is an airbender one is a
shape-shifter the other can control
computers and Bruno over here has metal
arms and can grow wings also Makoto can
sometimes have wings and they both have
this weird silly looking face paint I
don't know the series also came out in
the era where Marvel kept saying no
X-Men don't exist because we all have
the movie rights [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and
humans are the new hotness so they get a
particularly big Spotlight here and all
the kid Heroes got their powers from
like a terrigen crystal I guess
I don't mind seeing more Black Bolt
though I love that guy
clear the way
[Music]
for this shows Kang the Conqueror and
it's something to watch with him in it
while we're waiting for the movie
version in a few years you know you mean
to tell me you've never watched Earth's
body's Heroes all the way through but
you watch 50 what
51 up sorry 51 up sorry 55
sorry of disc Wars and 39 episodes of
this yeah cause Deadpool is in these
it's really that simple all right fair
enough you know if you say so voice cast
is half returning voices from disc Wars
half new voices to sound more like the
movie counterparts hey show us your big
feet why don't you Captain Marvel
like they got that faux RDJ voice from
what if in here I prefer Matt mercer at
this point this voice just reminds me of
Jarvis initiate [ __ ] and ball torture
protocol and Thor is played by the guy
who always voices scorpion you really
are a foolish lad
but however foolish
I cannot deny your bravery we got to
keep specific as Deadpool though
hey what's up big man looks like
something's bugging you
I think I know what's got you down
you're worried about all your new powers
you fear them and at the same time
you're trying hard to understand them
but you're not alone I'm here for you
buddy I'm glad we had this Heart to
Heart the only toyotic role play
accessory toy stuff in this show is the
uh future Avengers watches that activate
their costumes plus it has an AI that
looks like a silly talking octopus good
day at least I believe it's day you
talked
[Music]
download complete disco is reborn Jesus
Tony why'd you dumb it down so much
they're pre-teens they're not five
for some reason this in disc Wars just
refuse to acknowledge that Hulk can turn
back into Bruce Banner I guess it's
easier to keep the team roster smaller
and more focused since banner and Hulk
are technically two separate and
distinct characters but you know maybe
one episode with Bruce would have been
nice this show has a few strange little
quirks that set it apart I suppose I
don't really care for this Show's
serialized story arcs because they're
kind of boring and over dramatic and I
just I don't care about Kang that much
but but it has a lot of really
entertaining one-off episodes that are
on the light-hearted side that I would
recommend here are a few of my favorites
they did it down to earth Hawkeye
episode where he just nurses a sick cat
back to health in his apartment and then
it gets weird halfway through when he
puts a little Iron Man suit on
slingshot wait
both this and disc Wars have a clip Show
episode halfway through to catch you up
on what's happened in the series so far
but in future Avengers it's
intentionally a really stupid episode
where visco the AI octopus goes Rogue
things get weird and [ __ ] hilarious
[Music]
what wasp is yours Odin has slipped and
injured his back BRB
father oh wasp your kindness has always
been your greatest weakness think about
it with your stealth abilities you can
topple all regimes if you just abandon
your moral s man you'll never catch
bisco now Captain America
viscose right
I am helpless
season two is just generally way weirder
and funnier than the first ironically
disc Wars was a lot more grounded than
this
otherwise this Show's big thing is
trying to recreate Aesthetics and
moments from the MCU as closely as
possible it used to be contained to just
Iron Man but now it's more widespread
occasionally something more comic book
you will slip through like this Miss
Marvel origin episode or a three-part
event where Green Goblin sends the Hulk
on a rampage and steals the Hulkbuster
suit or a team up with kid Kaiju who's a
more recent addition to the comics
those are the parts of the show that I
found the most fun to watch but
everything else in between is just like
I don't love it nearly as much as disc
Wars but I suppose it's fine
it's definitely more accessible both
figuratively and literally you can
actually just watch this one in its
entirety on Disney plus one of the
biggest streaming services in the world
hey Disney Japan or whoever if you want
to discourage piracy make your shows
easily viewable through legitimate means
so piracy isn't even necessary
if you let me watch these shows
officially then I absolutely will until
then though
uh
yeah
you know after going through all of this
I just realized something what's that is
there anything in these shows that
contradicts them all being part of like
a single timeline the Marvel anime
universe
sure the character designs and the voice
casts change from time to time but
they're also really consistent for some
characters Matt Mercer is Iron Man in
particular appears a lot you think it
matters that they're really connected
not really but it's fun to see the
little potential connections Iron Man
and disc Wars mentions his dark past
with Iron Monger which is implied by
that and technivore kind of just
confirms it's the same as having stain's
death recreated him showing up in disc
Wars doesn't necessarily deconfirm this
because comic book deaths and Tony is
really surprised to see him so maybe he
has to use the same come coding in disc
Wars to go to space as the Iron Man
series and even though the process is
different the final results kind of look
the same and he describes it like it's
something he's done before I wonder if
Iron Man 3 got the Gemini armor having
the white color scheme from this show
and or Armored Adventures graviton has
the same design almost in disc Wars and
like Avengers Confidential which is just
the respite's heroes design so that's a
connection
Magneto is mentioned as being in prison
in X-Men but shows up later in disc Wars
maybe like escaped in the time since
beasts in both shows and has relatively
the same design
Deadpool is pretty much the same across
disc Wars and future Avengers future
Avengers has about the same team line up
as disc Wars
little twink boy Ezekiel stain pops up
again in the age pretty well if I do say
so myself some of his lines imply that
him and Tony have fought before so it
might be the one from technivore he does
something a little more comic accurate
in comparison to his Nano suit but it
could still be a possibility one of the
only things that pokes a hole in my
theory is that Bucky's appearance and
alleged death in disc Wars and future
Avengers are different with the former
version of Captain America believing he
was killed by Red Skull and the latter
seeing him explode on a plane crash on
Mission
the other biggest problem with this
theory is connecting disc Wars and
future Avengers because the Avengers
themselves act like they've never met
blizzard before in future when he showed
up for an episode of disc Wars in both
of these versions of him are like super
different so who is this charmer anyway
well he calls himself blizzard other
than that this theory is really helped
by crossovers always being punctuated
with the characters going oh yeah I know
that guy and having an implied history
off screen so no two characters ever
meet up for the first time twice as far
as I can tell on these shows I'm glad I
dug deep into these shows seeing as how
Marvel's animation on the western side
of things hasn't been a huge priority
for the company in the last 10 years and
the quality of these Series has been a
little up and down it's nice that the
Marvel Universe has been getting a lot
of love from Japan slightly more mature
stories more detailed and exciting
animation more unique stories from the
usual stuff we see in the U.S shows
makes this lineup a lot of fun to watch
and catch up on and I do hope that
Japanese Studios keep making shows like
this for some time DC only has the like
two of these so far so there was less to
make a video about there but you know
more of that too please personally I've
always thought it was a no-brainer to
make a Spider-Man Shonen series he's a
teenage superhero with immense strength
that fights monstrous villains and has a
rotating cast of potential love
interests and girls with different
colored hair it's such an easy
connection somebody get on that
Gwen and MJ you know like the the wee
Wars will start again they finally get
to a debt that James Cameron see where
he comes in his shorts that's like not
out of line for Japan
right oh Jesus Christ and also check out
disc Wars when you get the chance that
show's fun I I can't recommend it enough
thanks to Muzzy for helping me out with
this video be sure to check out his
channel because his solo stuff is
incredibly funny and insightful and who
knows maybe I'll pop up over there from
time to time way to go slingshot
[Music]
foreign
[Music]